well it is such a pleasure to meet you
it's lovely to meet you too like a
living legend an icon at this point
it's crazy it's been so many years yeah
you've written a memoir why
oh boy you know what there was a long
long time I didn't know whether I'd ever
do it yeah and I think
oh it's quite scary you know to go back
and to reveal all of those things and
I'm a really honest person and I knew if
I was going to do it I had to do it
properly but I've had some incredible
times and I think being on stage with
the girls in 2019 when we did some
stadium shows in the UK it was such an
incredible moment for us when we looked
out over the audiences and I think for
the first time it began to really sink
in this impact we'd had not only on a
generation of people but we've got
younger Generations who are still
discovering us and we all felt so proud
and for me lots of things started to
fall into place I started to reflect
quite differently than of course with
the pandemic I think we all had time to
kind of be a bit more still and to think
a little bit more and it felt like a
good time to tell my story yeah was it
nerve-wracking putting it together like
how did you feel emotionally writing
these moments ah it was all of the
things you know because obviously
incredible times with the girl as you
know extreme Highs but then Life Is Life
you know and often things get thrown at
us and obstacles we have to overcome so
there's some low moments and in fact
some of the more difficult moments were
the most important things to get into
the book you know I want some of the
things I've been through some of the
issues I've dealt with I wanted to get
it out there to potentially help other
people yeah did you share it with the
other Spice Girls and if so what were
their thoughts I did I spoke to the
girls and they were all very supportive
and there's only Emma left to write her
Memoir which I'm very much looking
forward to
um but all the other girls have done
them previously so they were very
supportive and full of advice and then
really helpful because I don't know if
you're like me but sometimes my memory
has little gaps in it so when we're
together we do reminisce and we kind of
fill in those gaps for each other which
they help me with the book and then as
soon as I got it to a point I was happy
I was like I want them to see it I want
them to be comfortable and they've just
been lovely throughout yeah I know that
your mom was a singer do you feel like
you were destined
to be here you know it's funny because
even though my mum was a singer and I
think I took for granted that there was
so much music around me because my
stepdaughter bass player too so there
was always rehearsing and we were always
going off and watching her perform and I
didn't think too much of it I knew I
wanted to be a performer but I started
dancing that was kind of my passion was
moving towards musical theater where I
knew I wanted to work in music but I
knew how hard it could be and then yeah
I was so lucky ended up in a girl band
and that became the Spice Girl so yeah
I'm so glad you got into dancing because
them car wheels girl okay it just added
spice to everything you know it's so fun
because you know I love performing
dancing singing acting but I also love
sport you know cliche but you know when
I was at school I was doing Athletics I
was doing gymnastics and it was just so
fun to kind of incorporate all of that
into my Spice Girls Persona yeah well we
appreciated it thank you
I cannot imagine having to fight for
wannabe to be a debut single as iconic
as it still is it still hits it still
puts you in a good mood what was that
fight like what was the hesitation well
we were so lucky yeah because within our
contract We Had Creative control which
when you think about it these young
girls no experience thank goodness the
people around us who were looking after
us looked out for us in that respect and
we just knew it was a pure introduction
to who we were as a band and who we were
as people you know that energy and if it
wasn't the first single we felt it could
never be released you know so that that
was our argument luckily we won the
argument and the rest is history what
are your thoughts on the legacy of it
what does that feel like oh my gosh you
know we're so proud and every day I want
to say every single day I'm approached
by people who talk about how the Spice
Girls has given them confidence given
them somewhere to belong and it's just
amazing you know it's been wonderful to
see the change in young girls and the
positivity and people really celebrating
the individuality and they are all the
things we obviously the music we're so
proud of but I think how it's affected
people in a positive way is the thing
we're most proud of yeah all of those
songs are still iconic they still mean
so much girl power meant a lot to me
when I was young I remember how it made
me feel and you guys brought that to the
Forefront what is that like for you oh
it's so incredible and it's funny
because it all came about quite
naturally it wasn't something we we
thought a lot about we went into the
music industry we wanted to make music
we wanted to be famous we wanted to
travel the world to do our carpets do
other things and then we experienced
sexism in the industry you know we were
told to govinds don't sell girl pop
bands don't sell you know because young
girls want to buy records by boys and we
were like we ain't having that we need
to be a girl band for the girls and and
that's where we started talking about
girl power and it was just an
interesting time in the 90s you know
because obviously feminism has been
around forever but sometimes it felt
quite academic and intimidating and we
feel like with the Spice Girls we were
able to make it more mainstream you know
younger people could kind of grasp hold
of something that maybe they wouldn't
have fully understood till they got
older and I think when you when you have
that feeling when you're young it can be
very powerful yeah you opened up a lot
in this book and talked about the highs
and the lows but they're inspiring for
people who are reading them one of the
moments you talked about was almost
being kicked out of the group because of
a argument with Victoria I couldn't even
imagine you not being in the group
um what was that like for you and how
did that impact you going through being
in the Spice Girls yeah it's funny
because at the time I didn't think that
much of it but when I look back and
started to examine my younger life and
the kinds of behavior that came after
certain points there was this moment we
went to the Brits in 1996 and it was
before anything was released so nobody
really knew who we were and you know we
we had a good night we had some
champagne and like as we were leaving
there was just a little disagreement and
it wasn't a big deal it wasn't a big
fight but I just tell Victoria where to
go and I didn't think anything of it
really you know we often have a little
little word with our friends don't we
after a night out especially and um the
next day I was just in a lot of trouble
and it was threatened that I'd be kicked
out of the band if I ever behave like
that again and it made me realize I had
so much to lose and something I thought
was so trivial could have ended up being
catastrophic for me and
um at that point I just thought wow I
have to control myself I have to control
my behavior and that escalated you know
with lots of other things along the way
the you know the success was incredible
but there was a lot of pressure on us
and the media attention and so so you
know that ended up being quite unhealthy
for me but that was one of the moments
that I was struck I remember thinking
you know I have to be careful if you
could go and talk to the younger you
before Spice Girls had a huge amount of
Fame before it started what would you
tell the younger you
I would say stick to your guns speak up
for yourself you know I think a lot of
young people they kind of we're so
like when we're young we're so full of
Courage aren't we and we said we know
what we want and we're not afraid to say
and I think sometimes as we get older
people can like quieten us down and we
start to lose confidence in our own
instincts and beliefs and I would always
urge people to really nurture that
because I know you know any mistakes
I've made is because I haven't trusted
myself and I think you know what's best
for you you know better than anybody
else yeah you talk about moments as well
you know your struggles with mental
health and you know an eating disorder
and I I really genuinely related to a
lot of those moments so thank you for
sharing those
um what was that like for you
to even just expose yourself in this way
in a memoir because those are like dark
moments that you're sharing yeah yeah
you know being a spice girl we have been
written about so much especially in the
UK you know our Tableau press is
ruthless so for many many years when we
were really young there was lots written
about us we were criticized you know
commented on sometimes things are
written about us that weren't true
so in a way it was nice to be able to
put things into my own words and I think
because of the experiences I've had you
know I've suffered with anorexia and
binge eating disorder anxiety and
depression and sadly many many people
experience these things and I know when
I was feeling you know and going through
those things if I heard anybody speak
about it or I read about it it was a
real Comfort to me and I just thought
you know what in this book it was one of
the most important things about writing
this book
to be honest and open and very
descriptive because it's so isolating
and can make you feel very very alone
and you know I just want anyone to know
anybody out there you know who may be
going through any of this you're not
alone you know don't think you're you're
the only person that's ever felt like
that please reach out and and I hope
this book can be the beginning of
somebody finding help for themselves
yeah I mean depression and anxiety can
be so consuming for the average person
let alone tabloid press huge amount of
Fame which is already isolating in
itself but you guys survived
in a space where social media hadn't
really started yet
are you happy that you guys didn't have
social media 100 oh my goodness oh my
goodness right so I mean this this good
and bad in everything yeah and one of
the things I would have liked yeah if
we'd have had social media is that you
have a voice you know back in the day we
were written about and we couldn't
respond to it unless we were in another
interview and your words often can be
twisted mostly in print media yeah but
you know it's also it's quite difficult
to to get your your words across so um
yeah social media would be useful for
that but yeah I think that the constant
scrutiny and just it's there the whole
time you wake up in the morning I know
so many of us it's the first thing you
do isn't it you look so there's no
Escape you also talk about working with
left eye yes oh that was so sweet it's
so amazing I mean even now you know all
these years later I just feel so lucky
that I had that opportunity and you know
it's so poignant because when Spice
Girls were starting out you know we used
to look up to so many great bands and
artists and TLC was you know one of the
Bands we were like wow they're so cool
you know we'd really love to do
something like that and then yeah to
work with her never be the same again
was my first UK number one as a solo
artist and I believe it was Lisa's first
UK number one as well so yeah so it was
it was really really cool and you know
so tragic when we lost her she was so
young and such an incredible talent but
I feel very very lucky that I got the
chance to work with her yeah yeah you
you know you're speaking up now and
you're sharing this Memoir but there was
a time where you didn't necessarily
speak up because you weren't
probably because you weren't ready and I
couldn't imagine
going through what you went through
before a show because before a show was
such a sacred time it's really you have
to be in the right headspace for it and
you kind of protect your
your circumference pretty much but in
the book you wrote about a situation
with a masseuse before show in Istanbul
I can't imagine that was easy to write
what was that like for you yeah you know
it was it was something that actually
wasn't in the book originally yeah and
when I actually woke up one morning and
it was just in my mind and I thought
whoa that's so wild because I've gone
through my life chronologically and of
course the shows in Istanbul it was the
first ever big Spice Girl show wow it
was such a huge moment but I'd erased
that thing and I think I had because it
was on the eve of such an incredible
huge day for us all that I I just had to
get on with it and it was buried and I I
wanted to put it in the book because I
think so many people and obviously you
know being a woman it's my experience so
many women have these moments you know
it was what I would call a very mild
sexual assault but you know regardless
we shouldn't feel or belittle that or go
oh maybe I'm wrong or maybe I'm just
making a fuss in all the things I felt
at the time because this person wasn't
held accountable and that's my biggest
regret and um yeah so it's just to you
know to hopefully again give people
courage to go you know what if you feel
uncomfortable in a situation with
somebody
then it's wrong you know if they make
you feel uncomfortable then something's
not right yeah what do you love most
about being a mom
um so funny I just got off the phone
with her and she was being really moody
with me because she's 13. so I'm like no
but being a mum is the best thing it's
the hardest thing but it's the best
thing and she's the absolute light of my
life I'm so proud of her she changed me
she changed she changed my life and I
think she's going to change the world
she's amazing I love that do you think
that she's well has she ever gone on
YouTube and like
Googled you and like looked at all
because there's a lot of moments to be
seen well watch when we fall out if we
have a little argument and she'll like
pull up like really bad pictures of me
oh that's what she does she's so mean
yeah but you know what she's secretly
proud of me yeah but um she's 13 so I'm
very embarrassing at the moment
subscribe where you are in this point in
your life oh gosh where am I you know
what it feels like a really good time I
think obviously so many incredible
experiences and it's so lovely to kind
of relive them through the book I really
wanted to let people see behind the
scenes of lots of iconic moments whether
it's the the Brits the night Jerry well
the Union Jack dress or just before we
met Prince Charles for the first time
and all of the idols that I've grown up
listening to and adoring I got the
chance to meet and I've shared all of
that in the book so it's been really
nice to look back and I'm here now and I
still make music and I still have
opportunities to work with the Spice
Girls and I DJ Now which I love and I'm
just like wow I'm so proud of what I've
achieved but I'm so excited about the
future as well yeah we have the 25th
anniversary Spice World insane yeah Mel
B posted something I feel like she's
starting something with this whole hey
when is Mel B not starting something
let's be honest yeah you know so here's
the deal we did shows in night 2019 yeah
and we were always intending to do more
we've got this incredible show and we
know we have fans all over the world
so you know things happen 2020 yeah Miss
Turf 2021 and we've continued to talk
and it is something we want to do and I
really hope and pray in the future you
will see the Spice Girls Back on stage
um but yeah it's not going to be in the
immediate future